>> Laura: IF A SOCIETY IS BEST
JUDGED BY THE QUALITY OF ITS
MERCY, BRITAIN'S SOCIALIZED
MEDICAL SYSTEM IS FAILING.
EIFFEL EVANS IS DYING FROM A
CONDITION THAT DOCTORS HAVE BEEN
UNABLE TO DIAGNOSIS.
HE WAS TAKEN OFF A COURT ORDERED
LIFE SUPPORT.
HIS FAMILY WANTS TO TAKE HIM TO
ITALY THAT IS OFFERING HIM AN
ALTERNATIVE TREATMENT AND
CITIZENSHIP.
HERE TO DISCUSS WHAT THIS TELLS
US ABOUT SOCIALIZED MEDICINE,
NIGEL.
THANKS FOR BEING HERE, NIGEL.
I'VE BEEN PRAYING FOR ALFIE AND
HIS FAMILY, BUT I HAVE A
QUESTION FOR YOU TONIGHT.
HOW CAN COURTS IN THE E.U. AND
THE U.K. PREVENT A FAMILY FROM
REMOVING THEIR CHILD FROM A
HOSPITAL AND TAKING HIM OR HER
TO ANOTHER COUNTRY FOR
TREATMENT?
HOW IS THAT EVEN HAPPEN
SOMETHING.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IS THE
RIGHTS OF THE PARENTS TO DO WHAT
THEY THINK ARE RIGHT ARE BEING
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM.
WE HAVE A CASE HERE -- IT'S NOT
THE FIRST.
WE HAD A BIG ONE LAST YEAR
REGARDING A LITTLE BOY THAT
WANTED TO GO TO AMERICA FOR
TREATMENT, TREATMENT THAT WAS
NOT AVAILABLE IN THE U.K.
IN THIS CASE, FOR YOUNG ALFIE,
THE TREATMENT WAS AVAILABLE IN
ITALY BUT NOT HERE.
THE LITTLE BOY IS SICK.
BUT ANY PARENTS, ANY PARENT IN
THE WORLD WHO HAS A CHILD THAT
IS SICK WOULD MOVE HEAVEN AND
EARTH IF SOMEBODY ELSE COULD
OFFER THEM A DIFFERENT
TREATMENT.
YET WHAT HAPPENS HERE IS OUR
STATE-RUN MEDICAL SYSTEM DECIDES
THERE'S NOTHING ELSE THAT CAN BE
DONE AND BACKED UP BY STATE
COURTS, THEY MAKE A DECISION
THAT THOSE PARENTS ARE NOT FIT
TO MOVE THEIR CHILD SOMEWHERE
ELSE.
THE POPE HAS INTERVENED, THE
PRESIDENT OF ITALY GRANTED HIM